the Joe Rogan experience his podcast has
rabid fans like whenever they do these
Garth Brooks things yeah oh my god Garth
Brooks is haunted he doesn't know what
to do he's so trapped by your mom's
house fans yeah they just won't stop
with the memes and the deep fakes with
James face over Garth Brooks body by
diem the deep fake guy yeah and because
I was like is it hard cuz it's
terrifying someone said she did it Jamie
used the software to make one with me
with Trump's head was this easy yes
someone I was talking to somebody about
it and they said it bums me out in the
way death used to bum me out when I was
a little kid I know what he means it's
like unfathomable like oh this is not
good jong-min
check this out are you talking about
which vice president I'm sorry former
Vice President Biden looks like me if I
was fat and I had a crazy haircut - look
that's me everyone's competition I knew
everybody that's so good
how long did it take for real it's about
that I was teaching myself how to do it
really I feel like this version took I
let it run overnight because there's a
little bit of what the machine learning
kind of thing is doing the longer you
let that run the better it is it's right
I've been learning so this was just my
test of like eight hours maybe could
have multiples going at once you're once
you're in a hopper the crazy thing is
porn they're doing that with gals
they're taking like you know love the
give you use word gals weird [ __ ] I
love it this is a good time to bring
this up because I just saw something
today literally and it has to do with
this and I don't know if this is real
but this sounds it sounds scary and this
is where someone's taking this
technology into a weird place a ladylike
is a Facebook post it's why I don't
believe it but she said she was with her
son and while she was out of her house
her husband was called saying that her
son was kidnapped and that he heard his
son's voice saying hi mommy help me help
me help me and that give him money and
it
I was freaking out didn't know what to
do did couldn't get a hold of them and
for finally did after six minutes and
she said they couldn't even convince the
dad that that wasn't real like after
hearing no I'm fine we're fine I'm with
them but I don't know if this is even
real to how they could do that at this
with the capability now I'm not sure but
they might be able to
oh for sure they can do it yeah thank
you boy I mean if they can do it with
faces they can do with audio they did it
with Tupac at the Coachella like five
years ago that was the way he said
Coachella is exactly how he would have
said it and they have that that hologram
that looks just like him but look a
little more jacked just a little yeah
like you went to CrossFit yeah yeah
that's I can I totally believe they can
do the voices seven years ago for that
one yeah they're so close now even if
you go back and watch Game of Thrones
like season one and what the wolf's look
like they look like [ __ ] really yeah
they were their shitty CGI wolves a
little clunky but now they look amazing
now it looks like a real [ __ ] wolf
what is this that's too Park look look
how Jackie is do you have any idea
situps you have to do to have stomach
like that you got to be on that Wiz
Khalifa it's all cells routine it's also
you got to not eat any starch right I
mean any sugars of any kind you can't be
[ __ ] around with carbs carbs it would
keep you from being really shredded I
mean not all carbs but I mean either
doing some a lot of fasting you got to
do something to get your body fat down
that low cuz it doesn't matter how many
sit-ups you do right it's not gonna blow
sit-ups make your ab muscles bigger yeah
and make them more defined I can see one
of mine yeah you gotta lose weight the
only ways to guys want to see that
[Applause]